I am beautiful what does it mean to you
when you hear these words do you truly
believe that you are beautiful without
trying to want to be someone else ladies
it is International Women's Day today
and I want each and every one of you to
know that you are beautiful and that you
are enough so being in the health and
fitness industry where unfortunately the
outer appearance seem to be the
number-one obsession with most people I
find that it is very important for us to
know that beauty is beyond skin deep so
I just want to take the time to share my
experiences and tips on how to build a
better body image especially with the
heavy influence of social media nowadays
the first tip is to be aware of your
influences so how many of you are on
Instagram Facebook or snapchat how often
do you check your social updates every
day or every hour well guys I just want
to start by saying that I don't think
social media is negative it is just a
medium for people you and me to convey
our message we the users have the
ultimate control on what we choose to
put out and also the messages or images
that we choose to take in so the people
whom you choose to follow have a huge
impact on your body image and also
self-esteem whether you're aware of it
or not every images and every messages
that you read everyday will either add
value to your life and make you feel
inspired and positive or let's face it
sometimes it will make you feel less
about yourself and [ __ ] about your life
so personally I am very selective over
whom I choose to follow on social media
I tend to follow friends or family
members and only people whom I know will
add value to my life and people whom I'm
always inspired by so I don't follow a
lot of people because I don't really
want to skirt through my Instagram or
Facebook every day just looking at
images of people who are just for
instance obsessed with how they look and
to be honest because social media is a
big part of my work and my life
as much as I can I only want to attract
things that will add value and will
continue to motivate me and inspire me
so just take the time to scroll through
your Instagram or Facebook page and ask
yourself why do you choose to follow him
or her is it because he has a very good
photography skill and I'm constantly
learning something new or is it because
she is motivating me and inspiring me if
so then by all means continue to be
inspired and influenced by them but if
however you feel that this person is not
adding any value to my life then
sometimes having the courage to remove
the negative vibes will actually help
you to build a better body image of
yourself the second tip is no more
comparisons be honest when your friends
or celebrities post pictures of their
perfect life dip down you might feel
envious and wish that your life were as
perfect as they are here's a fact what
you know about a person is only through
the lens most of the time it is never
100% true
they would portray their lives as how
they would want you to perceive it or
are you hooked over the number of likes
you get or are you envious of someone
you know who might have more followers
than you have based on my personal
experience I used to pay a lot of
attention to the number of likes I get
when I post up an image and if the
picture doesn't get as many likes as I
hope I would feel that you know what it
might be a bad post and sometimes you
can get so hooked and influenced by what
you think your followers would like to
see you ended up creating a fake reality
or an edited reality just to get the
number of likes up of course having
engagement from you guys is great I love
reading all your comments and all your
feedbacks but I have to remind myself
not to get hooked on the lights so
nowadays whenever I share a picture I
would always ask myself what is it that
I'm just trying to convey to my
followers will it add value to their
lives
it influenced them and motivate them in
a positive manner does it reflect the
real me and my world so I believe that
social media can be a very powerful and
positive platform for you and me to
share our messages and share our life
stories but it shouldn't be used as a
platform for you to compare yourself
with others and for you to feel less
about yourself we all came from
different backgrounds and we all have
different life stories and that is what
makes us unique and beautiful the third
tip is know your values in order to
build a more positive by the image
you've got to know your values know
yourself and embrace that so for
instance when it comes to exercising ask
yourself why is staying fit so important
to you is it because you're overweight
and you know that you need to lose
weight for your health is it because it
makes you feel good gives you more
energy and gives you more
self-confidence or is it just purely a
vanity thing if it's just pure vanity no
matter how fit and how good you look
from the outside I can assure you you
will never feel good by yourself and you
will never be happy so being in the
health and fitness industry I can tell
you that there are a lot of good-looking
people who look really fit on the
outside and you know what a lot of
people wish that they have their bodies
but these people are just constantly
self-sabotaging
and you always hear the negative
self-talk so oh my god you know I feel
so fat oh my God my thighs are so big oh
my god I've eaten so much today it is
just constant self-sabotaging because
they're basing their values on what they
look on the outside not what's on the
inside so when I first got into this
industry I would say that subconsciously
I was drawn into this car as well I saw
food as something negative something
that would cause me to gain weight
rather than something that would nourish
my body and no matter how much I've
progressed in my workout it is always
never good enough or I would still look
into the mirror and feel fat okay it's
it wasn't a good time and when I started
to look deep within and started to
embrace my values and when I started to
surround myself with people who aspired
to live a healthier and happier life
from within not just on the outside I
find that I became more at peace with
myself and that I became happier and in
fact I became more in love with fitness
this leads on to my next point which is
to love yourself
what does loving yourself means it
doesn't mean that you know this is who I
am and you can't change that I'm going
to look after myself too bad if you
don't like it or I'm going to do
whatever that makes me feel happy
and I don't really care how you feel
loving yourself
doesn't mean any of that in fact it
means that you know you're responsible
for your self-worth emotionally
physically and mentally you look after
yourself a new workout because you know
that you're responsible for your
well-being you don't find a need to
compare yourself with others or sick of
validation from others you know that
you're not your height your body weight
or how flat your tummy is and most
importantly you're able to forgive
yourself and be kind to yourself once
you start to embrace your values and
love yourself you will find more balance
in your life attract more happiness and
more positive people into your life
so no more self sabotaging or negative
self-talk and the final tip is to create
a positive space as much as we can blame
the media and it's negative influences I
feel that we have a responsibility and
role to play as well if you're on social
media you too have the responsibility to
either spread positive messages or vice
versa so what I want to do for the next
four weeks is for us to create a
positive online space by sharing your
pictures your worlds inspirational
quotes and any uplifting messages okay
so this may not only empower you but it
can also inspire your friends and also
follow us so I've listed 28 different
it's for each day remember there is no
right or wrong to this this is your
creative space so express yourself and
share with us what the word means to you
remember to hashtag I am beautiful and
Jaso inspiration make a profile public
so that we can all view your pictures
and stay inspired okay I will also be
selecting five winners who post Twitter
pictures continuously for the next 28
days to win my favorite tank top be
confident be happy beautiful okay take
this time and make this next four weeks
of the time for you to discover yourself
your values and to build a more positive
body image so get your family and
friends on board and inspire each other
remember to stay true to yourself
because I want to get to know the real
you okay and if you want to be part of a
more inspiring and more positive fitness
industry and if you want to become a
personal trainer then do check out the
National Academy of Sports Medicine
online personal training cause they are
currently offering a 14-day free trial
so take this opportunity to learn more
about fitness nutrition understanding
your clients and waist on becoming a
successful personal trainer and if you
find that you know what this is the
career path that I really want to go
down because I'm passionate to help
others in regards to health and
well-being then by all means sign up to
the full chorus okay click on the link
in my description box for more
information and I'm really excited to
see oil pictures for the next 28 days
let's create a more positive online
space so start posting and start
inspiring those around you all the best
you